[Applaudissements]
prévisions c'était ou fait autant je
pense qu'avec la nouvelle équipe ils
vont vite mettre la clé sous la porte
[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue dans la roulotte de
nos valises à alors si vous regardez
c'est que vous êtes dépressif ou au
chômage ou les deux alors j'en profite
pour saluer tous nous téléspectateurs
bernard martin éric et c'est tout
profitez-en pour nos athlètes
si vous voulez poser des questions et en
indemnisant se feront plaisir d'y
répondre
bonjour denise à un jour jean marc rozé
décidément toujours au point jeudi c'est
incroyable comme vous avez dit mono
savez ça m'a fait penser à jeune grenier
tribus jusque là irréprochable côté
piquant premier téléspectateurs en ligne
il s'agit de philippe ils nous appellent
de meulan 1 217 voix l'a eu
bonjour philippe queuille votre question
voilà je vous appelle car je suis très
inquiet j'ai perdu ma petite chatte
saucisses je voulais savoir si j'ai une
chance de la voir revenir
eh bien écoutez philippe d'avancé désolé
que vous habitiez à me lob mais comme un
malheur n'arrive jamais seul vous avez
donc en plus perdu votre petite saucisse
ou votre gros chat je ne sais plus trop
en faire ses preuves
vous savez ça me rappelle un gondolier
très musclé que g koné avait mis nos
conventions linguistiques j'y reviens
toujours à l'heure verte aux survivants
monnier je peux continuer ses taux mais
ferme donné envie vous aider
aurez-vous qu'il était allergique aux
poils ham après le printemps
non nous invitons donc à aux oraux amis
non non c'est bon je crois que je
l'aperçois fausse alerte
elle est revenue merci les revenus bas
tout va bien balancé passe aussi ce que
vous arrivez l'apc bon bras bah oui vous
savez quand
[Applaudissements]